Without the use of their hands, astronauts
have to rely on other means to scratch various
itches.
For any itch outside of the face, retired
astronaut Clayton Anderson explained, “You
shake, rattle and roll, baby!
That’s the only thing really that you can
do to alleviate that itch.
Hopefully, between the incredibly bulky and
stiff suit itself and the liquid cooling garment
you are wearing beneath the suit, you can
wiggle your body enough to effectively scratch
that itch!”
Itches on the face can be a bit more tricky,
but there are things within reach.
For instance, under the helmet astronauts
wear what is sometimes referred to as a Snoopy
Cap that is equipped with earphones and a
microphone.
If an itch presents itself on the lower half
of the face, the microphone is one commonly
used scratching post.
The downfall of this method is that the action
sometimes moves the microphone out of position,
interfering a little with the sound quality
in communications.
blowAnother option astronauts use is the valsalva
device, which is a foam piece attached to
the bottom interior of the spacesuit helmet.
The purpose of the valsalva device is to allow
an astronaut to block up their nostrils and
blow to equalize pressure in the ears when
necessary.
Beyond its intended purpose, the foam block
is a handy device for scratching an itch.
Of course, you could potentially get a little
snot rubbed on the itchy spot if you’ve
previously used the humps on the valsalva
to stopper your nose, but desperate times
and all that…
scratchingA third option to address facial
itches is a strategically placed piece of
Velcro.
This was particularly used during the Apollo
missions.
(And, note, contrary to popular belief, Velcro
was not invented by NASA, nor specifically
for use in the space program.)
The astronauts would typically place the Velcro
on the little feed port flap that is held
closed via the pressure in the suit when out
in space.
Apollo 17 astronaut Harrison Schmitt noted,
“Everybody seemed to agree that you needed
that [Velcro]…”
If an itch pops up where nothing sufficiently
abrasive can be rubbed against it, the astronaut
simply has to endure, generally using the
distraction tactic until the itch fades.
This is easier than in some other settings.
A typical spacewalk lasts between five and
eight hours and being out there working is
incredibly laborious due to how stiff the
space suit gets when in the near vacuum of
space (even just flexing your fingers to grip
things is relatively difficult).
Between the straining and extreme focus needed
to complete some of the tasks the astronauts
are out there for, not to mention the absolutely
beautiful view and the knowledge that there
is very little between you and the near vacuum
of space, there’s plenty to get caught up
in and forget all about the itch.